I was shooting a commercial for rain
with uh Thor big Thor from Game of
Thrones you know he's like oh you know
who I who I Ruled with yesterday I'm
like oh he's like Goran Rhino how'd that
go and he was baffled so like I let Thor
start inside control full inside
position he's got everything like my arm
shelf and I'm like all right go and so
like I escape I sweep him and then I end
up submitting him and he's like man I
don't know what just happened I think
it's good for people to see that because
listen I've been around big guys when I
saw Thor for this time like that's the
biggest human I've ever seen like you're
so big dude it's out of control this is
good because when I meet like a regular
person who they just people like oh man
if the guy was just way bigger it would
never work now I can say I literally
grappled the strongest person on the
planet and I promise you Jiu Jitsu works